we actually have an announcement to that
we were gonna
maybe wait a little bit longer in the
broadcast but uh miley's actually
joining metallica yeah isn't that right
um my talent is finally founded
we've been talented in 40 years we
started out that's right we started out
looking for a singer
james wanted to play guitar and james
was singing to kind of for the first few
months just to keep it going so we could
get out of the house and that first
thought
and uh
but uh
all that's in the past now first of all
there are there are so many similarities
well first of all i'm gonna i'm gonna
talk about miley behind her back but
miley's difficulty in life is it not
that it's a difficulty but she really as
a kid was put on this disney show hannah
montana
and if and in a way it was harder for
her to prove her rock and roll
credibility
and the fact that she's a bigger singer
than than just pop music unlike
metallica who you know you guys had your
childhood and you could form your own
sort of vibe and what you wanted to do
on the other hand can you imagine uh
being like a seven year old or a nine
year old i don't know how old you were
when you started montana miley but it
was young and so you don't really get to
form your rock and roll identity if
that's what really is living inside of
you you know what i mean a lot of rock
and roll is also about making people
talk you know and and question and say
something and so that's why i had
originally covered nothing else matters
it kind of validates everything that i'm
doing which again i don't always search
for but it definitely feels good to know
that i am because there was a kind of
rocky transitional period for sure where
a lot of my fans um they feel dis you
know you kind of couldn't win they would
feel disappointed like by me leaving a
certain identity behind i would leave
them too but it's been kind of this
journey of taking them along with me and
the way that i've been able to do that
before transitioning my own music was by
doing covers elton i know i only have
you for a few minutes let everyone know
about miley can i just talk about marley
yeah let's talk about miley let's talk
first of all miley is i say this about
miley miley is a great singer and miley
is a great rock and roller
and she's gone through a lot to prove to
audiences that she can really rock with
the best of them i take great joy when i
uh look at miley's videos and underneath
you read comments like wow miley cyrus
can really rock man she's got the chops
blah blah blah blah but it's been a
rough road for her to prove herself in a
way right she had to she doesn't have to
after i mean she did some stuff at the
uh whiskey she did zombie um and i
talked to miles said girl you know when
this is all over you've got to go out
and get yourself a banner just [ __ ]
rot people's asses off because when i
heard her saying nothing else matters i
just couldn't believe it the low voice
that starts out and then it just
astonishing her voice and
you know she's probably the best rock
and roll singer out there without
question i agree it's been frustrating i
know it's been frustrating her because
she can't because of covet but she's
been itching to do this kind of [ __ ] for
a long time and now she can and people
are just going to be blown away by this
you